[Musik]
karlsruhe ps bis zum 10
[Gelächter]
jeder ist mit dem prix du und alle
glauben zu kennen
aber wer kennt pullover wirklich
als erster mundart rock sänger der
schweiz wurde er ein star
er war sprachrohr der hippies
man kennt ihn als clown und provokateur
in den letzten jahren haben der schwere
gesundheitliche probleme in diesem film
redet der entertainer über sein
hochgefühl und tiefschläge
[Applaus]
vor fast 70 jahren kammer als uhr sofort
zur welt
[Applaus]
die gerne hätten
[Musik]
ja
über 30 alben hatte eingespielt jetzt
nimmt er sein letztes auf
[Musik]
la la la scha la la la la vida lied i
die dunkle wolken
[Musik]
wildes leben tourbus das war einmal
heute rollte in der ersten klasse zu den
konzerten seiner entpuppt uhr endspurt
wird aus seiner letzten cd heißen nicht
aus altersgründen will aufhören sondern
weil es sich nicht mehr rentiert grüne
zwölf meter hoher verdienst galt aber
noch mit mit dem tracking
[Musik]
der neue soll ja ja
die polo hofer band ist bereits beim
soundcheck und wartet auf ihrem
bandleader
[Musik]
wenn ihr gewöhnlicher und der power oder
100 dich und energie
das macht mir atrium es ist weg es gibt
herum energie das ging es war ein
letzter soundcheck diesmal ohne den
sänger
er weiß wie man sich alsbald 70-jähriger
optimal auf ein konzert vorbereitet
polus ehefrau alice hofer hat sich in
den letzten jahren nicht nur beruflich
mit dem tod auseinander gesetzt
mehrmals musste sie um das leben ihres
mannes bangen
in ihrem atelier für angewandte
vergänglichkeit verkauft sie selbst
gestaltete sich das geschäft sei für sie
selbst therapie um sich mit der
endlichkeit des lebens zu versöhnen
angst vor der angst
die beiden lernten sich vor 15 jahren
kennen
es dauerte einige zeit bis es bei alles
punkte sie habe sich nicht in den sänger
verliebt sondern in sein wesen
es ist die griechische sprache die
sprache und kiki und ja als ich mich
aussie
[Gelächter]
um ihn herum sei es nie langweilig sagt
sie er sei geistreich und bringe sie oft
zum lachen
[Gelächter]
polo zeit galgenhumor
in den letzten jahren ist er mehr als
einmal dem tod entronnen
dagegen wurde und wird mit hier was die
größe ist welche die wanne sagte gaber
werde nicht gebrannt und dann nach
vielen rakete und einmal hatte er
herzprobleme dann eine entzündete
bauchspeicheldrüse zudem musste ihm ein
tumor und den stimmbändern entfernt
werden
[Musik]
tagelang nach der als lover klettern
ja ja die tat im august auf die
schwellen lexi toni kölner machen über
größter tmax klar machen dass er am
anfang schlecht die prognosen als
wissenschaftliche rat mit amerika machte
er sollte dank am auto aber wenn man da
schon sagte die stellen dass du angst
vor dem sterben vom stapel mit polenta
und also vom leader bruno wuchs in
interlaken mit drei brüdern auf der
vierte war zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
nicht geboren
die eltern führten an der marktgasse ein
kleidergeschäft
[Musik]
im bootshaus seines bruders bert ist der
sänger regelmäßig gast doppelklick auf
den besten und die fülle durch
fechter-bundes mit dem hund ich hole mir
genannte haare
ach gott wenn die fischfang größte
verschmutzer glyn lawcock salat der
sonnenuntergang beschluss 66 natürlich
wenn man hoch gewetteten entbehrt fisch
weil er ein passionierter angler ist ja
mit dem aids kirche talent geht vom feld
musste merck aber wenn es gesetzlich in
der 14
genau darum ob endlich los ist das ist
noch vollständig wende habe ich sehr der
spruch berufe oder das witzig auf die
bühne schon mal gar nicht wenn jemand
abgelehnt
einer der hofer brüder lebt in bern als
steuerbar
ein anderer wanderer nach kanada aus von
allen vier ufer söhnen war polo als kind
der ruhigste die toskana dominierende
donnerstag fotos liegt auf der bühne
steht laut machen kann
ganz in der nähe des bootshauses steht
eine ruine als pfadfinder wurde hier der
junge russe auf den namen polo getauft
im schaufenster k und das hätte ich mir
im partie für mich sein aber ich glaube
den fahrten bis solchen alte gebäude ist
blieb um sogar zum labrador der it
service gibt
die zeit bei den pfadfindern prägte ihn
an unterhaltungsabende lernte er seine
scheue art abzulegen der emittierte
louis armstrong und begann von einer
karriere als sänger zu träumen
doch der vater verlangte von ihm eine
lehre zu machen und so wurde er hand
lithograf
das interessante an vielen orten ist zu
machen die gespräche wieder sehr
naturalistisch hat er spaß gemacht hat
graf lernen sehen im zeichnerischen
begabungen kairo ägypten
nein wie der blick ins stade abzeichnen
hin und da ich heute bfm jährlich
terminen ältere hätte zum abschluss von
leer
bei dieser gelegenheit möchte ich doch
einmal sagen dass es ein ganz
außerordentliches gutes seltenes
zeichnerisches talent besitzt zusammen
mit seinen vielseitigen interessen und
seiner guten natürlichen intelligenz
könnte er bei richtige verwendung einmal
aussergewöhnliches leisten auf diese sei
auf dieses sein wo möchte ich dann mein
erstes glas leben und ihnen und ihrer
familie aus guten wünschen für das neue
jahr ist sich stets an der verband
reagiert die unter dem titel damals
wurden
[Musik]
mit 16 gründete er seine erste band mad
men pullover schlagzeuger und sänger in
einer person
[Musik]
dem vater missfielen seine musikalischen
ambitionen würden nach kuba gespielt und
18 20h dienen sie kommt und nachtclubs
interlaken mit striptease nach annaberg
folgen vor augen dass er nicht so locker
dass sie nach italien
aber ich verdiene musik alter ist
einziges mal als kontakt was du machst
aber du machst es gut einmal spielte der
batman als vorgruppe von pink floyd mit
gitarrist david gilmour kids so tauscht
sich über die micro
sein langjähriger cannabiskonsum brachte
ihm den titel oberkiefer der nation ein
aber auch mineralwasser sieht man ihn
eher selben trinken
dazu ist das so
aber wieso die weiterbeschäftigung
ja seinem wohlergehen zuliebe trinke er
heute weniger als früher aber die
bemühungen gesünder zu leben würden ihn
noch umbringen karl avatar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist doch schon heute technik
[Musik]
das und nation am meisten berührt nichts
mit diesem treffer bediente titel
grössten schweizer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der komponist
noch bevor sie ins auge fasste hanery
amman und polo hofer gründete 1971 die
hippie band rumpelstilz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die spieler
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das motto
das sei ein deutscher text und musik
machen
yahoo es ist einfach nicht die gleiche
selbstverständlichkeit sie eigentlich
überhaupt keine visio tisch sondern muss
ich einfach offen auf dieser achse wo
alle leute gefunden muss dass sie dass
das geht sowieso nie die pessimisten c
was war so fand using und so nicht
wirklich zu dritt oder züge dass das
dass das eine neue epoche das neues
neues berufsfeld musik
[Musik]
die idee mundart zu singen hat der polo
im gefängnis er behielt die orgel eines
musikers der die band zuvor verlassen
hatte und ein mal verkaufte er ein
schlagzeug das nicht ihm gehörte deshalb
musste er für 30 tage hinter gittern
[Musik]
das ist schlecht gesehen aber es ist
schlecht ich sehe dass ich im jahr vom
woodstock sie er hat aus lastwagen dann
im juni juli in wuxi habe mich ganz doll
kilometer würde aber eine einsame zahlen
muss auch besondere und die division
kultur am montag beim gesetz noch nicht
unter größtem sales
hanery amman komponierte bei rumpelstilz
mehrere hits polo war jeweils für den
text zuständig 1978 trennte sich die
band die musiker zeigten sich ums geld
und die beiden alphatiere ammann und
hofer haben miteinander probleme
eigentlich weiß nicht ich mag gestorben
dort leben mit problem getan aber das
ist nicht unbedingt der grund wieso das
5er zum zusammen schaffen nicht so nicht
so leicht verdaulich geschäftsführer der
was ist der wahre ziel dass ich sie traf
simonet ungefördert über zügig
weitermachen und das hat mir imponiert
das ist nicht nur schlecht sie mir jetzt
habe ich dennoch sehe mich sehr über
jahre heimlich gemacht jetzt trifft
jährige professionell tätig ist von
musik aber du musst größten liegt zusagt
und dass das kraut je länger das sagen
sie siehst du ihn mit experimenteller
musik hätte gar keine sein will braucht
wo sie so instrumentalmusik usedom
[Musik]
das verhältnis zwischen polo und hanery
ist bis zum heutigen tage angespannt
verbunden bleiben sie trotzdem als
erfolgreiche songschreiber du und mit
einem platz in hinterlassen der ihnen
gewidmet ist
[Musik]
schon anfangs der 70er jahre war hier
der mundart rock sänger stammgast polo
hofer setzt sich an jedem tisch am thema
politisiert wurde
er und weitere hippies gründeten hier
eine partei mit dem motto sie nahmen
härtli ein kamerateam war zugegen als
die frisch gebackenen politiker das
parteiprogramm ausheckten sie
kandidierten damit für den berner
stadtrat für sänger oder hippie
generation tatsächlich eroberten die er
glüht es mit madrid probst auch einen
sitz doch nach ablauf der
legislaturperiode wurde die partei
aufgelöst
am politischen geschehen sei nach wie
vor interessiert polo bezeichnet sich
als wechselwähler
anfangs der 70er jahre heiratete er
trudi die einen sohn mit in die ehe
brachte
[Musik]
doch das familienleben war alles andere
als harmonisch
das ehepaar stritt sich oft
häufiger anlass waren seine affären mit
groupies zugewandte seite greift das mit
ein grund sei die sorge und xhaka aber
so ist eben rock and roll kommen
das risiko mit medial ihrer musik
an seinem wohnort trifft polo seinen
stiefsohn oliver hofer mit dem
showbusiness wollte er nie etwas zu tun
haben
der 48 jährige lernte becker oliver hat
es als kind nicht leicht polo nahm seine
verantwortung für die familie kaum war
und in der schule habe er wegen ist
eines berühmten vaters leid erlebt
[Musik]
das ist so wie es ist ist sie setzte sie
die schöne 17 weniger aktiv werden ja
auch ziemlich vorteil einkaufsfahrten
alaba hätte einiges dafür
ist das normal
[Musik]
1978 tritt der sänger mit der gruppe
spannung aus sparen macht er sein
eigenes ding
hannovers schmetterling polo wollte eine
frau in der band haben und so entdeckte
er mariana police ist dass so viele
menschen so die autofahrer besser über
dich da kommt es ihm mit business sowie
mir bist machst du passt und das
natürliche oder mehr bass und dank sehr
guter profi holger spieler
[Musik]
ich stamme
b
schmetterling landete mehrere
gassenhauer aber die zusammenarbeit mit
dem bandleader verlief nicht ohne
zwischentöne weggekommen ist nach vier
jahren trennte sich die band bald sparen
wieder sparen sein wollte
die musiker lösten sich aus dem schatten
ihres sängers der seinen namen zur marke
gemacht hat anstatt also wo sie die
namen als brand bekannt machen und sich
richtig sie eine reform nach unter dem
titel größtes über träume
[Musik]
1984 kam der berner mundartsänger auf
die bühne zurück mit einer neuen
formation pullover und schmettern band
[Musik]
der letzte auftritt der schmetterball
das konzert von 2003 in der mühle und
segen statt
[Musik]
ich sage mit mir
wirtschaft
aus
[Musik]
18 jahre lang war die später band eine
verschworene gemeinschaft dann liste pro
low die gruppe auf alle eine
musikalische pause einlegen wollte seine
entscheid hat er alleine gefasst
[Musik]
er dankt irgendwie muss in suris trotz
geldnot einmal das noch kleinere
arbeiten seit einem jahr ist ethik immer
nicht beantwortet
ja natürlich exzentrik sie im moment
niveau was ist aus der er gekommen ist
wo ministerium weg nach oben nicht lang
bitten sie um spenden und durch schotter
bz sie haben sie das in ihrem haus
ich würde das ist schon ein punkt dass
sie keine ruhe in dem heck des opels und
feierlich und defa entrup
[Musik]
jeden dienstagabend trifft sich ja ja
das klappt mit seinem prominenten
mitglied willkommen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also es ist die musik quasi die
finanzierung des haushalts durch lässt
das wissen wir doch heute ist einfach
nach der vereinbarten die blaue wo sich
gehoben
die rubrik 215 kilo so ein spaß macher
ist ja aber wer versteckt sich hinter
der maske des clowns lässt es sich
überhaupt je in seine karten blicken
[Gelächter]
mit einem spruch länder vom thema ab das
scheint sein trick zu sein
das sponsoring schwung
ich habe die ganze geschichte nie lektor
recruiting und wenn der domain
spezialist rico nicht wie ich das
englisch also die fina sprach wirklich
gespräche über eine situation vor ebenso
wie heißt du mit ihm am telefon oder
eventuell uhr wieso baut das analyten
sie konnten viele erhoffen
mit ihm sei ja schon länger zusammen als
mit jeder frau sagte pohl hans peter
brüggemann gemeinsames musizieren
während 30 jahren ist die basis ihrer
freundschaft
brüggemann steht im sänger näher als die
meisten anderen
die sache vor
es ist ja so dass eine kleine
schwierigkeit aber kranke etwas tut
nicht gern wenn es wirklich nur sieht
der in familiär was gibts nen bisschen
geld also wenn es nun morgen mit
metallringen berger tour turnier mit
problemen oder sehr ungern
wir hätten gerne mit dem wie bei jedem
problem mehr geräte wie das apple gar
nicht erfassen wollen wir lernen immer
wieder bringt ich starke schmerzen und
das müsse bei einer grenze schmerz
den schmerz lernte er durch den tod
dieser frau kennen
isabel ediger war sieben jahre lang
seine lebenspartnerin 1996 starb sie an
krebs
sie wird immer gerade 36 jahre alt
[Musik]
ja dort aus ruft anderthalb jahre und
das ist im juni 2007 haben sie gemacht
ich habe ich alle musik auf ihr
equipment und das ist sehr viel
also was voraus für mit isabel und der
vorgeschichte als ganze krankheitsphase
vor ihrem ziel ist der siebte von boni
wirklich bis denne nicht erkennen denn
ist aber die sensibilität und die
verantwortungsbewusst der euro und der
hat wirklich das geld demnach als
verantwortlich war
diese ist
[Musik]
im märz nächsten jahres wird es 70 nun
steht er nochmals im aufnahmestudio um
sein angeblich letztes album
einzuspielen
es soll im frühjahr 2015 erscheinen
er verlässt sich auf sein bewährtes
musikalisches rezept mundart rock
inspiriert durch amerikanische
südstaaten musik
[Musik]
jesus hätte es an die routine war josef
smartphone immer wollte sagt nur die
güte was zu tun
[Musik]
eigene songs komponiert er nicht seine
stärke liegt im schreiben der texte
[Musik]
sie hätten versprochen
das update nicht
[Musik]
aufhören villa weil der cd-verkauf
eingebrochen ist aber der 70 geburtstag
im märz nächsten jahres sei ein guter
grund etwas kürzer zu treten
doch mit seinem letzten album werde der
rock senior nochmals zeigen wer der
könig des mondautos ist das ist der
grund dass eigentlich nach dem brand
[Musik]
statt
ich habe
keine rembrandts felsen aber echte polo
werke wahlen so sieht es eine zukunft
[Musik]
ja
khedira oder studieren ist im
archäologie dass die eta plötzlich licht
klang ist sie als kritisch nachher alle
plötzlich da und das ist stockhausen
stimme ist nadja wie ist nämlich dass
man die start stopp von renten
es sieht so neugier die sache dass ronny
deckt macht
nachdem kurz danach betraten die szene
wir aber auch die meinen oder die
striptease konter der gorillaz ii
[Musik]
ein bereich der geschäftsmann ein spaß
macher der seine sensible seite schützt
50 jahre bühnenerfahrung er findet es
munter drucks zahlreiche evergreens das
macht ihn zur helvetischen ikone wo
etwas eindeutiger älteren kolleginnen
sind oft nicht ausreichend glückte
bezüge und oasis verdienst ist dass es
auch möglich bemüht relativ komplexe
zusammenhang illedits bringen im monat
lesen und vielleicht ob im zugang nichts
machen was im schnitt hatte belegt die
architektur inspiriert hätten der mut
machen
[Musik]
der war
doch kann
[Musik]
noch ist der mit seiner im sport uhr
nahe bei seinen fans aber schon bald
werde er aus der brand licht treten
vielleicht
[Musik]